wo es hin soll er zaubert er zögert
diskussion
jetzt gerne vergessen welche rolle
ich haben wir auch eine verantwortung
aus deutschland wir haben in der
dastehen mich alles zu trotzdem finde
kanzlerin merkel gespielt hat in der
biden zusammen mit ukrainischen freundin
ja ich glaube wir sind sozusagen relativ
vergangenheit viel für ein welche
ich man sollte nicht alle verantwortung
putin umarmung und auch bei nordstream
verantwortung was fordern sie für mich
geschaut so beiden der angekündigt hat
jetzt bei einem bundeskanzler der glaube
einig zumindest was das
zwei aber lasst uns bei der spd bleiben
kommunikationsverhalten von olaf scholz
ist ganz klar wenn man wenn man zu der
ich 120 tage im amt ist jetzt abladen es
dass man haubitzen schickt dass man eine
auch wenn wir uns bestimmte ja
aussage kommt dass wir kein
angeht ich finde es spielt noch etwas
gab eine vorgängerregierung die also die
eigene drohne schicken wird und dass man
vollständiges gas-embargo überhaupt
stellungnahmen von spd-politikern
breiten linien dieser regierung schon
eine rolle in den vergangenen tagen
millionen milliarden weitere militär
energie in bar oder sehr zurückhaltend
anschauen was den vergangenen tagen ralf
wieder so viele politiker aus allen
gezogen hat der hvv merkel in
ist da kann man lange darüber streiten
stegner bei markus lanz gestern wirklich
vergeben will richtung deutschland und
ob er das embargo oder nicht also ich
verantwortung olaf scholz regiert nicht
ländern hier die ministerpräsidentin von
die freude hier in der ukraine
dramatisch wie er sagt naja am ende
persönlich wäre bereit mehr zu tun ich
alleine es sind drei parteien dirigieren
dänemark der ministerpräsident von
darüber war riesig aber überein da darf
finde es richtig dass wir sozusagen den
also wenn es wirklich das allgemeinen
spanien wir haben den euro präsidenten
werden die ukraine verlieren gegen die
druck auf putin auch nicht das wasser
man kaum noch sprechen hier in der
empfinden ist innerhalb der ampel dass
gesehen also dieses deutsche beleidigte
große russische armee deswegen muss man
reichen wir stehen jetzt mein wagen ich
ukraine
man eine komplett andere ukraine politik
das ist olaf scholz unser bundeskanzler
die auch nicht so wirklich so ganz viel
bin sehr dafür dass was auf europäischer
leberwurst spiel weil ich würde mir so
betreiben soll dann sind auch die
unterstützen dann michael müller
nicht nur dass er weiterhin keine pläne
ebene beschlossen wurde dass cola in
anderen ansprechpartner innerhalb der
lenz geht der ukrainische präsident
immerhin ehemaliger regierender
basel zu machen wo deutschland ja auch
rausgenommen hat jetzt nicht jubeln
koalition gefragt nichts woche
im bremserhäuschen das dass wir das
bürgermeister von berlin hat die drei
hat nach kiel zu fahren sondern er macht
entscheidende debatte im bundestag
ausweiten auch auf die ölimporte man
frank walter steinmeier zu umarmen das
vielleicht wird man dann sehen wie die
abgeordneten strack-zimmermann rot und
kann das ja sozusagen die zeitlich
sich hier immer mehr feinde denn die
ampel zu der ganzen sache steht und zum
strecken das kann man überlegen aber ich
steht auch für sich also ich kann nicht
finde wir müssen mehr machen wir haben
ukraine sagen weiterhin da kommt viel zu
hofreiter kritisiert dass sie hier waren
anderen muss man auch sagen es ist auch
verstehen warum ich zumindest die
eine sehr sehr schwierige entscheidung
als deutschland eine verantwortung und
sich das angeschaut haben also wir
außenministerin warum nicht zumindest
wenig aus deutschland und ich glaube so
natürlich ist es für ein bundeskanzler
diese verantwortung der müssen wir
hatten nicht mal im kiosk sondern in der
gerecht werden in der von europa und
die bundestagspräsidentin wenn olaf
schwieriger zu entscheiden als für einen
west ukraine und hat dann gesagt ja das
langsam macht olaf scholz deutschland
auch der welt und wir werden aktuell in
scholz stand ich will hier her zu fahren
leitartikler der fordert jetzt holt man
sei schon ein problem dass diese
da sagt man immer ja das ist ja
lächerlich respekt täter hat heute
emotionalisiert zurückgekehrt sein also
den letzten wochen dieser verantwortung
hier die ganzen schweren waffen raus und
nicht gerecht unternehmen massiven
symbolpolitik das sollen die anderen
getitelt olaf scholz wird zum
dann ist die ukraine in zwei tagen
die realität verdrängt der
machen nein das wäre gerade jetzt so
außenpolitischen schaden an dieser
wieder befreit was wir uns alle rufen
wichtigsten verbündeten von wladimir
sozialdemokratie in diesem krieg ist
stelle das wäre aber nicht mein thema
würden also olaf scholz macht fehler
wichtig um dann auch die deutsche
putin das ist einmalig ein deutscher
aber ich finde wir haben auch eine
wirklich einmalig und ich glaube das
position zu erklären wenn es denn so ist
olaf olaf scholz hat eine schlechte
verantwortung gegenüber der ukraine und
kommunikation seine eitelkeit seine
bundeskanzler der auch in der
fällt ihnen wirklich auf die füße wenn
wie christine lambrecht sagt dass wir
der wären wir nicht gerecht und deswegen
internationalen presse mittlerweile
arroganz teilweise steht ihm im weg aber
eine art ringtausch machen mit
man jetzt mal darüber nachdenken welche
glaube ich dass scholz muss seiner
zerrissen wird und auch national egal wo
osteuropäischen staaten dass wir dort
bitte laden wir nicht alle verantwortung
konsequenzen das auch für die spd hat
führungsverantwortung die hat als
panzer hin liefern und dann aus den
man hinschaut spiegel faz bild bei uns
ich glaube sicherlich hat olaf scholz
bei ihm abschauen wir auf die
bundeskanzler endlich folge leisten wenn
osteuropäischen staaten wirklich viele
vorgängerregierung schauen wir auf die
sie mich heute fragen würden was ist
überall heftige kritik an bundeskanzler
teilweise recht dass die deutschen
panzer her kommen dann ist das ja
jetzige ampel regierung und nehmen wir
eigentlich die deutsche position beim
ausnahmsweise mal eine gute nachricht
sicherlich zurückhaltend sind was
thema lieferung von schweren waffen
bitte auch ernst es ist eine sehr sehr
zum einen liegt das daran dass viel zu
herunter hat die pressekonferenz
schwierige abwägung die nun der
aber man muss dann auch zeigen dass man
schwere waffen angeht aber was viele
wenig passiert viel zu lange gezögert
bundeskanzler für die ganze regierung
angesprochen ich könnte es ihnen nicht
in zwei sätzen sagen weil es ein
der für das ganze volk letztlich
und gezaudert wird denn wir sind in
hinter der ukraine steht und dann muss
jetzt wird bekommen ist dass es bei der
durchführen muss aber genau das ist ja
furchtbares geschmuggelt war sehr
woche 7 weil den woche acht dieses
spd der sehr viel weiter geht nämlich
man hier endlich mal herfahren und sich
der punkt olaf scholz ist in
krieges und noch immer kommt nicht
komplexes thema ist also wer wäre er
dass man in wahrheit immer noch nicht
das selbst anschauen ich meine ich finde
verantwortung gewählt worden er ist der
genügend hilfe aus deutschland das ist
es als deutschland der jetzt seit über
deutsche bundeskanzler und er hat ja mal
realisiert hat was hier wirklich
jetzt beim reden zugehört hat schon
einfach fakt aber das zweite problem von
zwei monaten hier ist als reporter
passiert
diesen satz der häufig zitiert wird
bevor er bundeskanzler wurde und danach
olaf scholz das im wahlkampf nie so
vielen dank paul dass du uns abgehört
wirklich peinlich dass der
gesagt wer führung bei mir bestellt
richtig rüber kam aber jetzt ganz
wusste was er meint der verbringt den
österreichische kanzler hier war dass
hat noch wieder aus kehrt berichtet hast
bekommt sie auch aber von führung sehe
deutlich wird er hat ein unglaubliches
literatur und intelligenz nobelpreis ich
alle möglichen anderen hier waren dass
war saftig auf und wir hören uns befehl
ich persönlich nichts und wenn sie
ursula von der leyen hier war und das
darauf hinweisen das ist ja die gesamte
kommunikationsproblem diese
nach achter nächste woche wieder du bist
habe nie ein wort verstanden was er
noch wirklich kein deutscher minister
pressekonferenz wird in die geschichte
amt der regierung in verantwortung ist
gesagt hat weil er grundsätzlich so
ja sonst bei bild live immer da und
ja das stimmt man sieht ja die
verschwurbelt inso in chats
eingehen als eine der peinlichsten und
kein deutscher kanzler einen fuß in die
schachtelsätzen spricht als ob er
berichtes dankeschön
fliehkräfte dies da gerade schon gibt
wir hören von anton hofreiter von den
der arroganten pressekonferenzen die ein
gewollt nicht verstanden werden er will
ukraine gesetzt hat paul meine frage an
grünen von anderen protagonisten der
nicht verstanden wer will nicht viel
deutscher bundeskanzler jemals gehalten
lieber nicht verstanden werden als
grünen die sagen wir müssen schwere
dich ist ist das ein problem
hat und er hatte noch nicht mal eine
falsch verstanden werden das ist eine
waffen liefern wir hören von agnes
deutschlands und das ist ein
strategie das steht auch in seiner in
spezifisches problem der
nachricht er hatte noch nicht mal etwas
strack zimmermann die vor ort was ich
der biografie drin die neulich
sozialdemokratischen partei deutschlands
was er wirklich erklären wollte ich
informiert hat und jetzt einer der
also wenn man wenn man wenn man anschaut
erschienen ist und das ist glaube ich
finde olaf scholz muss sich erklären es
das problem damit kommt man einigermaßen
vehementesten verfechterin ist dass
wer die exponenten der deutsch
gut durch hamburg einigermaßen sie
deutschland mehr tun muss und ich kann
braucht eine ansprache an das deutsche
das nur absolut unterstreichen ich finde
russischen freundschaft war der fall
hafengeburtstag da war es dann auch die
es persönlich schmerzt mich wirklich
volk eine erklärung warum er was tut
laut der spd nahm einen ist es ein ist
grenze des witzes erreicht in der
wenn internationale presse titelt das
bundesrepublik ist es gerade so einer
das ist das historisch gewachsen ist das
egal welche meinung hat muss sie endlich
krise ein problem aber ich würde ihm
nach wie vor zutrauen geben wir in
besser erklären denn ansonsten sind wir
wir als land die stärksten unterstützer
woher kommt das du hast du verfolgst die
dieser woche noch nächste woche im
in deutschland bei wirklich
spd seit seit vielen jahren woher kommt
von putin sind das ist wirklich etwas wo
bundestag wird sich einiges tun und da
international der lächerlichkeit
muss energisch bewegung hinein sonst
diese diese diese beißhemmung gegenüber
wir uns auch sommer strategisch
preisgegeben
würde ich diese zeilen von spectre auch
russland in der sozialdemokratischen
innerhalb von europa und der welt nicht
unterschreiben wohin gehen noch einmal
ja ich denke es gibt tausend gründe
brands heimat zurück in die debatte er
nur der lächerlichkeit preisgibt das mag
partei deutschlands
warum im urlaub scholz momentan den
ja ich glaube du hast recht das ist
ja dass einer sein aber ich finde mit
kann sich ja selbst die einschreiten ich
idealen watschenmann abgibt und für die
bin froh wenn er wieder hier im studio
meisten gründe ist er selbst
schon ein gewisses spezifisches problem
blick auf die ukraine wenn wir sehen die
verantwortlich das ist völlig klar
ist heute was ist geradezu gehört mit
bilder einfach mario pohl wo die wo die
wobei bei aller debatten und natürlich
schlechte kommunikation man weiß nicht
gehört deine meinung zu unserer bis
menschen jetzt eingeschlossen werden
ausgehungert werden sollen dann finde